[Musique]
et
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
la mort d'un énième homme noir georges
floyd tué par un policier blanc aux
états unis a causé une telle vague
d'exaspération d'indignation à travers
le monde que pour la première fois
depuis trois mois le camp à virus qui me
police notre actualitté a été relégué au
second plan alors pourquoi cette mort là
pourquoi georges floyd aux états unis
rendez vous compte 54 pour cent des
américains soutiennent les manifestants
c'est inimaginable comme en france ou
même le ministre de l'intérieur est
obligé pour la première fois de
reconnaître qu'il peut y avoir des
violences policières et du racisme dans
la police alors comment et pourquoi la
mort de georges floyd et à créer un tel
club cataclysme pour en débattre nous
avons habité va doumbia qui est auteur
et metteur en scène de théâtre
votre pelé pièce le yach
sera jouée à la rentrée et sera édité
par la même occasion aux éditions actes
sud
le yach ça traite de la famille d'une
famille afro européenne et des violences
policières vous était également membre
fondatrice du collectif décoloniser les
arts qui me dit qui milite pour une
meilleure représentation des minorités
dans les arts mais qui lutte aussi
contre les relents coloniaux dont notre
culture serait encore imprégné d'après
vous alors ma première question et va c
est ce que vous attendiez
quand vous avez vu ce qu'on a pu tous
voir malheureusement de la mort de
georges le fleuve est ce que vous
attendiez à un tel une telle indignation
un tel soulèvement alors moi je n'ai pas
pu regarder les images
quand j'ai su que j'assistais à la mort
de quelqu'un en direct j'ai coupé les
images évidemment je m'attendais pas à
ça parce que et en étant sensibles et et
est mobilisé sur la question des
violences policières puisque deux parce
que de par de par mon histoire familiale
et est ma couleur de peau
je ne m'attendais pas à ce que parce que
un jour en fait il ya un tel événement
et que c'est qu'un tel événement une
telle mobilisation en fait à la fois
national et international je trouve que
c'est une chose assez incroyable qui
s'est mis en place
en vérité je pensais en jeu craignant
que que le cas américain monopolisait
l'opinion et les médias français et le
fait qu'enfin soit reconnue d'une part
la violence que subit la famille traoré
et puis toutes les autres familles je
pense à la famille dieng je pense à à la
famille ben tounsi je pense à la famille
camara
toutes ces familles en fête qui ont
perdu quelqu'un je suis très on va dire
heureuse puisque on préférait que les
choses ne soient pas arrivés là mais on
va dire que je suis très satisfaite et à
m
et dans la tente et dans l'espoir que
les choses changent
j'en ai fait le nicole belloubet donc
ministre de la justice
examiner le dossier de la mort d'adama
traoré nous invite également normal à
jarry qui est philosophe
norman à jarry qui enseigne à villanova
university aux états unis vous êtes
l'auteur de la dignité ou la mort
éthique de la politique éthique et
politique de la race aux éditions de la
découverte même question vous attendiez
à quelque chose d'aussi énorme pour la
mort je rappelle la mort d'un énième
homme noir un tué par la police
oui absolument non je m'y attendais pas
exactement même si en réalité j'aurais
dû vous avez dit dans votre lancement
que cet événement avait relégué au
second plan la question blaco vie de 19
mais en réalité ces deux événements sont
à mon sens étroitement liés puisque
comme on le sait aux etats-unis de très
loin les premières victimes de cette
épidémie ont été les personnes noires et
notamment les hommes noirs ce sont
également des personnes qui sont sur
représentés dans les emplois de service
les emplois 10 des travailleurs
essentiel donc l'exaspération des
personnes noires aux états unis en ce
moment n'est pas seulement lié à cette
mort d'une personne noire tué par la
police
c'est une exaspération qui est lié au
fait que ils n'ont pas accès à des soins
ils sont dans une situation de précarité
immense et ils ont été éreintés par les
quelques mois qu'on vient de vivre ils
ont été lessivés par là la précarité
dans laquelle ils ont été sages d'une
certaine façon ça a été la goutte d'eau
qui a fait déborder le vase
il y en a eu d'autres armes aux ordres
et qui a été tué par deux personnes qui
sont improvisés en justicier et qui
n'ont tué qui l'ont assassiné parce
qu'il faisait son footing en bas de chez
eux ils ont assimilé un cambrioleur jeu
pas comme on cambriole en tenue de leur
tenue de jogging mais en tout cas c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont su
poser
donc là on avait quelque chose avec des
images frappantes accablante
il est certain que ça a déclenché
quelque chose qui a déclenché une
volonté politique une volonté de faire
des demandes de faire des réclamations
démocratique
on met tout ça ne se place pas hors de
tout contexte au contraire il ya le
contexte de ces violences multiples qui
ont rendu aux états unis est extrêmement
sensible
l'objection noir qui est la règle depuis
400 ans
notre troisième invité ses mahboula
soumahoro qui est docteur en
civilisation du monde anglophone
bonjour ma boule à vous enseigner à
l'université de tours vous êtes
présidente de l'association black
history month ans en france qui comme
aux états unis célèbrent la contribution
des noirs à l'histoire du pays
vous êtes également l'auteur du livre le
triangle l'hexagone à la découverte des
pieds venu en parler dans cette émission
moment de 7 de sa sortie c'est un essai
sur votre identité noire en france même
question mahboula est ce que vous
attendiez à de telles conséquences à de
telles à une telle indignation à travers
le monde pour la mort de georges floyd
alors bon soir frédéric bonsoir et
vaille danseurs norman je voulais juste
préciser que je viens de public sénat la
l'instant c'est pour ça que je suis en
retard et je viens de vivre une scène
hallucinante avec la police et un taxi
un taximan noire qui s'est fait crier
dessus comme un enfant de 5 ans et je
trouvais ça très intéressant de vivre ce
moment alors que je me destinais à venir
parler de toutes ces questions avec vous
donc pour les gens qui qui pensent que
tout cela n'existe pas que ces épisodes
de nos vécus n'ont pas lieu je viens
d'en vivre
1 il ya même pas dix minutes mais pour
répondre à la question donc commencer ce
débat est ce que j'ai été surprise
peut-être que j'ai été surprise par
l'ampleur des mobilisations et l'ampleur
qu'elle soit nationale sur le plan
étasunien mais nationale au niveau
français et national
enfin internationale pour toutes les
autres mieux du monde où se sont tenues
des manifestations l'ampleur est
surprenante mais elle est somme toute
assez logique au vu de la deûle à des
circonstances exceptionnelles de la
période et qui implique justement cette
cette crise pandémique internationale au
delà de ça on peut
aussi se demander pourquoi aujourd'hui
une fois qu'on a éludé évidemment la
question delà du contexte de santé
publique et du contexte socio économique
actuel on pourrait se demander pourquoi
georges floyd de plus que armand darbary
plus que brio n'a dès lors plus que
treize jeunes martin puisque rokia boy
puisque enfin toute la longue litanie de
noms qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait
égrainé lorsque l'on parle des violences
policières aux etats-unis tout en
sachant que cette longue liste de
victimes de violences policières
pourrait également être française mais
c'est vrai que jusqu alors on n'avait
pas trop fait attention depuis la france
hexagonale à ces violences policières
qui pourtant qui pourtant existe aussi
de ce côté de l'atlantique ce qui s'est
passé avec cet engouement pour la faire
pour la faire georges floyd c'est que
les associations françaises ont
capitalisé sur cette attention
médiatique elles ne sont pas du tout
dans le mimétisme puisque quand on
reproche cette importation d'événements
étasunien sur le territoire français et
2 et que ces associations se
trouveraient dans la pure imitation pour
imiter il faudrait au moins on peut se
mettre d'accord sur le fait qu'on a
besoin de morts et des morts en france
aux mains de la police ou d'autres
victimes qui sont blessés ou qui sont
arrêtés ou condamné injustement
on les a aussi en france donc c'est pas
du mimétisme c'est juste une peut-être
une stratégie qui est davantage payante
actuellement au vu de la configuration
nationales et internationales lors ce
qui est très frappant depuis la mort de
georges floyd et peut-être c'est ce qui
diffère par rapport à de nombreux autres
morts parce que dieu sait s'il ya eu des
hommes noirs tué par des policiers
blancs aux états unis et dieu sait s'il
ya eu des vidéos depuis georges yeux de
rodney king en 1991 dont l'arrestation
plus que brutale avait été elle aussi
filmé en vidéo
donc tout ça on connaissait mais là pour
la première fois me semble-t-il sa
excède les
initiation sort de la communauté noire
américaine qui a l'habitude qui
s'indignent depuis depuis l'abolition de
l'esclavagé pour ainsi dire et qui
pendant très longtemps alors que la
ségrégation a régné pendant un siècle
après l'abolition aux états unis les
noirs étaient terriblement seul pour
lutter pour résister hollywood avait
beau être peuplée de d'acteurs de gauche
libéraux comme on dit là bas on n'en
voyait pas beaucoup pour défiler avec
les noirs pour s'indigner des conditions
de vie et d d d d interdiction qui
frappait les populations noires aux
états unis y compris à hollywood à los
angeles ou à new york là pour la
première fois on a l'impression que la
population blanche
une majorité d'américains donc les
blancs s'indignait son tour soutient les
manifestants et puis ça sort ça ça
embrasse le monde entier et puis la
france notamment et là aussi ça n'est
plus seulement les noirs ou les
organisations antiracistes c'est toute
la population
et là j'ai l'impression que c'est
quelque chose de très différent qui
arrive avec georges floyd je ne sais pas
s'il va doha et va évaluer ensuite oui
vas d'accord parce qu'il ya plusieurs
choses qui se superposent j'ai parlé du
cas français puisque c'est celui que je
connais bien c'est que pendant le
continent on a assisté on aime les gens
étaient étant obligé d'être chez eux les
gens regardaient énormément ce qui se
passait sur les réseaux sociaux et on a
assisté
on a vu beaucoup d'arrestations
violentes dans les quartiers populaires
dans les cités et d'arrestations et de
et de violences policières qui ne me
n'est pas forcément à la mort mais qui
était de toute évidence raciste ensuite
je crois qu'à une histoire de génération
c'est à dire que les gens qui sont dans
la rue sont majoritairement jeunes et je
pense qu'il ya des choses qui qui ont
été gardées il ya des concepts des idées
qui sont pour une certaine génération
acquise et qui ne veut plus du monde
qu'on leur propose et un monde qu'est
fondée construit sur une idéologie
raciste on
c'est que la société capitaliste
occidental s'est construite sur le sang
des victimes
avec la force de travail de personnes
colonisés on va dire qu'elle est faite à
partir du négrier et donc il y à toute
une génération qui pour qui l'injustice
de cette donnée là et étaient inscrits
est un acquis et il me semble que c'est
ça va alors il me semble que c'est ça va
dans le même sens que le mouvement
précédent de grande ampleur en france
quels mouvements des gilet jaune ou ou
en fait on n'a plus confiance dans les
politiques on a plus confiance dans le
gouvernement ça succèdent aussi à la
crise du coronavirus ou en vérité on
sait que les personnes qui étaient les
plus touchés les plus les plus exposés
étaient les personnes qui travaillaient
dans les services et donc il y avait
énormément de personnes racisées en fait
qui était qui était susceptible avec
victimes du virus dont je crois que ça
ça arrive avec un et ça arrive avec une
volonté que les choses changent c'est à
dire que yalla yalla mort terrible et
est injuste de ces deux personnes
adama traoré et d'orge floyd mais il ya
aussi une volonté de voir la société se
modifier parce que vous exagérez pas un
peu pour le capitalisme qui se serait
construit uniquement sur la traite
négrière le capitalisme étant née en
italie et aux pays bas deux pays qui
n'étaient pas spécialement esclavagiste
j'ai un peu ça vous exagérez un peu il y
avait quand même d'autres façons de
fabriquer de la richesse des la
renaissance de nos pays des pays et
d'aisance des anciens péter pays qui ont
été des pays colonisateurs
c'est vient devient des biens et de la
force de travail de des êtres et des
êtres qu'elle a réduit en esclavage ou
qu'elle a colonisé et aussi
les richesses qui ont été captés c'est
un point de vue non rien mahboula et
verbales à durer au delà de ce point de
vue on peut citer donc la thèse de
doctorat qui est devenu un ouvrage très
connu un classique de l'historien de
l'île de trinidad
enfin à trinité et tobago dans la
caraïbe qui s'appelle le capitalisme et
esclavage et qui est une démonstration
scientifique universitaire du rôle qu'a
joué la traite négrière transatlantique
dans l'accumulation du capital et dans
la fondation des sociétés capitalistes
occidentales ça c'est plus qu'une
opinion c'est une
c'est un travail si on est scientifique
y est le nom est d'ailleurs eric
williams et plus tard de est devenu
premier ministre de trinidad enfin c'est
très bien on n'aura pas le débat mais
j'entends vos arguments ils ont l'air
d'être solide
néanmoins alors non non manajary je
reviens pourquoi george frey décrit un
peu le le encore une fois il y avait eu
deux déjà de tant de choses vous citiez
le vous citiez le com comme l'a fait va
le coronavirus le fait que ce soit des
hommes noirs qui aux états unis
notamment et en et été les victimes
privilégiées
mais encore une fois ça excédé tout ça
aujourd'hui pour que ça arrive jusqu'à
chez nous et que ministre de l'intérieur
reconnaît ce qu'il n'a jamais voulu
répondre à reconnaître pendant plusieurs
mois de mouvements des gels et jaude à
savoir qu'il y à des violences
policières
il vient de le reconnaître là et il a
fallu georges floyd quoi ouais mais tout
d'abord il faut il faut bien dire pas
pour rentrer directement dans ce débat
sur le capitalisme l'esclavagé le
capitalisme est ce qui me semble
indéniable c'est que au moins en 20e
siècle aux états unis la classe
révolutionnaire c'est la classe mois y a
qu'à penser aux black panther party y a
qu'à penser à au black power n'y a qu'à
penser à la black liberation army et
donc la classe la plus révolutionnaire
aux états unis
la classe si j'ose dire qui a mené
toutes les actions les plus radicales et
qui est levé les programmes y compris
d'un point de vue socialiste et plus
radicaux ça a toujours été les
organisations noires et c'est pour ça
que les blanches
puis viennent se greffer là-dessus parce
qu aux etats unis si on veut un
programme radical c'est les noirs qui
représentent la mèche c'est les noirs
qui commence et les noirs qui frappe en
premier et il est certain que je suis
pas certain que ce qui est véritablement
effrayer castaner se soit
particulièrement l'image de john floyd
saluts et saluts coeur je pense que ce
qu'il écrit yes et les images de
centaines de milliers de manifestants
initial philadelphia il ya eu cent mille
manifestants
rien que samedi dernier dans les rues j
étais c'était absolument phénoménale on
sait les images de commissariats brûlé
c'est les images de palais de justice
brûlé je pense que c'est cette
radicalisation de la lutte et cette
volonté de véritablement m ce que lui
représente dans la version française
c'est à dire eh bien tout simplement un
système de mettre ça en l'air aux états
unis la contamination dont il a eu un
avant-goût avec les gilet jaune je pense
que c'est ça qui l'a effrayé il était
obligé de lâcher un petit peu de lest et
d'une certaine manière c'était peut-être
une concession
je ne sais pas je suis évidemment pas
dans sa tête mais c'est juste une
hypothèse que je peut soumettre au débat
une espèce de concession de 10 rebonds
parfois il ya des racistes qui font des
trucs comme ça mais dans d'autres cas
dans d'autres situations se sont pas
véritablement des violences policières
c'est du maintien de l'ordre etc
je pense que il y a une concession
partiel pour essayer de ne pas admettre
l'institution policière comme une
institution intrasèquement violente ce
qu'il a dit c'était finalement pas grand
chose il dit bon il faut punir les
policiers quand ils sont racistes mais
quel premier ministre va dire ça quel
premier ministre même si on imagine un
type du rassemblement national
il va pas encourager à une heure de
grande écoute
les polices et raciste d'ailleurs il a
lâché un tout petit peu de lest mais il
a finalement pas dit grand chose
il s'est contenté d'avaliser une
situation on met ces il reste beaucoup à
faire reste beaucoup à faire en termes
de concevoir des réformes radicales de
l'institution on voit bien sur un
certain nombre de plateaux télévisés en
ce moment où il ya beaucoup de
commentateurs qui parlent de ce qu ils
font ce que nous faisons là mais mais
généralement il ya plus de blanc ou de
noir sur les autres plateaux
et qui disent tous ceux souvent la même
chose à savoir que si des noirs ont des
problèmes avec la police c'est parce
qu'il est cherche elle savoir c'est la
réflexion concernant le change aux floyd
qui je crois quelqu'un a dit ça n'était
pas un perdreau de l'année
on le dit pour la famille traoré de la
même manière on fait la liste de ce
qu'ils auraient reproché à savoir c'est
toujours la même chose
c'est à dire que la la violence ça n'est
pas les blancs qui ont commencé ce sont
les noirs et en france vous entendez ça
et quand le ministre de l'intérieur dit
bah on va créer une déontologie
etc etc se dire qu'il admet que la ville
avait de la violence puissent émaner des
blancs ce qui est déjà incroyable maboul
asu maro pour détendre
peut-être que pour détendre tout le
monde on peut on peut même aller au delà
de ces catégories noir et blanc et de
dire que es que la violence émane des
populations et des populations ciblées
des populations police et où est ce que
la violence émane de la de l'institution
policière
l'institution policière a le droit
d'utiliser la violence est elle qui
possède au sein d'un état le droit à la
violence légitime
d'accord mais si on fait si on lance un
regard ou jette un regard sur les cv de
délinquance de toutes les personnes qui
sont victimes de violences policières
l'un des arguments les plus simplistes
vraiment j'ai j'utilise ce mot très
consciemment les plus simplistes serait
de répondre la peine de mort ayant été
abolie en france depuis 1981
calais qu'est ce qui pourrait justifier
le comment dire la mort pour des corps
ou des personnes qui auraient commis
commis des actes répréhensibles des
débits ou des crimes ou ce qu'on veut
sans parler sans parler des gens qui
n'ont rien commis de toute façon et qui
sont qui peuvent quand même être
victimes de la violence policière
mais lorsqu'on le compare le de mort qui
est le cas extrêmes est ce que la maman
en tant que sentence juridique a
vraiment disparu de notre société
française ou pas ça c'est une question
pour moi des plus des plus basiques
quand j'entends des gens faire les
les cv de délinquance de toutes les
personnes qui ont subi cette violence
extrême de la part de la police
regardez pas aux états unis là pour le
coup on n'est pas aux états unis et pour
le coup reconnaissons l'abolition de la
peine de mort dans notre pays mais alors
justement en france on met plutôt fier
on dit que notre police tu peux et le
alors elle tue plus que d'autres
notamment les polices du nord de
l'europe qui ne savent même pas ce que
c'est que d'utiliser une arme c'est
inimaginable mais on dit les français la
police française tu peux mais elle
tuerait plus de les populations racisées
comme vous dites que les autres jeudi la
police et on veut oui 2 au dernier volet
ce qu'il peut mais mais chaque mais
chaque mort est une mort de trop
puisqu'on parle d'une institution qui ne
peut-être qu'exemplaire sinon ça sert à
rien d'être policier on n'a pas le droit
à l'erreur quand on est policier
donc même si on est on a des chiffres
qui sont inférieures à d'autres pays du
monde
vous avez effectivement raison
d'insister sur le la proportion de
personnes qui sont tuées par la police
donc avant de rentrer dans des
considérations raciales ou ethniques
on pourrait et je pense que tout le
monde là se détendre et encore plus on
pourrait envisager des considérations
sociales c'est à dire que la police est
aussi là pour gérer les populations les
plus défavorables le mans
qu'ils appartiennent aux classes
sociales les plus les moins privilégiés
voilà on pourrait commencer par là et
ensuite si on accepte que deux parmi ces
classes sociales défavorisées
il existe plus de personnes qui sont
défavorablement racialisées on est juste
dans la logique donc oui il ya une
mécanique raciste il ya une mécanique
raciste eva doumbia
ben je pourrais aller dans le même sens
que magula c'est que si on s'interroge
vraiment sur ce qui me menait à ces
violences ya il ya plusieurs choses ya
d'une part la lune vient une violence
presque structurel de la police
française et puis d'un autre côté
lorsqu'on énonce le cv de délinquant des
uns et des autres peut-être si on
s'intéresse réellement au racisme on
peut se poser la question de savoir
pourquoi pourquoi en fait on trouve plus
de délinquance chez les populations
défavorisées c'est la réponse est
extrêmement simple c'est à dire que plus
de pauvreté plus de plus d'injustice et
on est en fait évidemment que si on
prend si on si on circule socialement
dans danser danser on circule
socialement on voit bien que la
délinquance avait associé à la pauvreté
donc la logique en fait le fait que les
gens et d aider casier judiciaire non
vierge est associée à leur condition
sociale et c'est très important de dire
aussi dans ma nage aride il ne faut pas
nier la délinquance il faut il faut il
faut se dire qu'elle est qu'elle qu'elle
fait qu'elle fait quelques elle
participe de cette de ce système qui est
injuste
norman à jarry oui je pense que cette
question de l'injustice est centrale
pour traiter notre problème il s'agit
pas simplement d'empêcher les policiers
de tuer des noirs des arabes et des
borniers les gens ce n'est pas
simplement ça il s'agit aussi de
réfléchir à son mode de fonctionnement
parce qu'il ya tout un tas de gradation
dont la mise à mort n'est que le pic
extrême mais il ya beaucoup d'autres
problèmes
rien que ce matin tout bon sur france
inter le défenseur des droits a rappelé
mon dieu chiffres que les personnes
arabes ou noirs dans ce pays avait vingt
fois plus de probabilités de subir un
contrôle d'identité
le fait d'être harcelés par les
contrôles d'identité c'est également un
problème et c'est également un problème
qui est très fréquemment ce qui conduit
à ces mises à mort par exemple mais
également à des outrages et rébellion à
des refus d'obtempérer qui sont des
infractions qui ont été causés par ce
contrôle d'identité lui même c'est à
dire que c'est une opération qui est
criminogène qui génère elle-même des
délits et qui en réalité ne sert à rien
et ne l'en empêche
aucun délit on est dans une situation où
à mon avis il faudrait mettre sur la
table
cette question simple ce problème simple
est-ce que le contrôle d'identité ne
devrait pas être aboli c'est à dire est
ce qu'il est normal que lorsqu'une
personne marche dans la rue elle puisse
de manière absolument arbitraire être
arrêté par un agent des forces de
l'ordre et qu'on lui demande de décliner
son identité
cela dans les pays anglo saxons dans les
pays où il ya ce qu'on appelle l'habeas
corpus est à dire la possession de son
propre corps et biens cela n'existe pas
ou en tout cas cela exige des
infractions seul exige des mesures
exceptionnelles
est ce qu'on ne pourrait pas posé la
question de savoir si nous sommes nous
mêmes des personnes dont le corps
devrait être au même titre que le
domicile également au même titre que les
biens inviolable est-ce que c'est ces
affaires qui peuvent déraper en violent
comme on l'a vu dans la sphère théo est
ce que on ne devrait pas être protégé
que un type simplement parce qu'il a un
badge puisse venir vous voir vous palpez
demandé de décliner votre identité et c
est ce qu il faudrait pas que tout cela
exige une enquête existe comme on dit en
anglais mme probable cause c'est à dire
que l'on soit dans une situation vous
est suspecté véritablement quelque chose
et que cet arbitraire qui consiste à
pouvoir choisir n'importe qui est le
porte procéder avec lui de manière
absolument arbitraire à n'importe quel
examen
est-ce que cela n'est pas quelque chose
de fondamentalement foncièrement
antidémocratique
moi je le pense je pense que ces
histoires du
traçable de traçage de traçabilité du
contrôle d'identité dont on parle tout
bon ce n'est pas suffisant cette
histoire de caméra ventrale dont parle
le ministre de l'intérieur ce n'est pas
suffisant mais qu'on pourrait vivre dans
une société tout à fait vivable tout à
fait raisonnable dans laquelle le
contrôle d'identité tout simplement
n'existe pas et on contrôle simplement
des personnes qui sont effectivement
erea est réellement des suspects car
cette mesure du contrôle d'identité à
mon avis le péché originel du racisme
structurel de la police c'est à dire
c'est ce qui constitue son droit au
racisme on s'arrête là le temps d'une
pause et on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
comme d'habitude on rajoute de la dette
est ce qu'on aime ça on aime beaucoup la
dette pour la première fois on parle une
tête commune à mes yeux c'est tout à
fait nouveau
est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez des
gens qui dans ce pays bas ou en france
vont vouloir aller payer des impôts pour
les grecs tout pour les italiens alors
monsieur moto pour l'italie et à
l'espagne sont allés principaux
bénéficiaires
c'est un message fort selon vous envoyez
à ces pays du sud qui se joue dans cette
histoire c'est la marche en avant de
tous les pays de toute l'europe l'europe
est morte
enfin acté kelly morte
[Musique]
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne pour
profit de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président en train de pratiquer le déni
en oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu
le triste privilège d'avoir le plus
grand nombre de morts dans la deuxième
garde
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat pourquoi la mort
de georges fenech floyd at elle eu de
telles conséquences avec eva doumbia qui
est auteur et metteur en scène de
théâtre sa place pièce le lien jeu sera
jouée à la rentrée édité par actes sud
mahboula soumahoro qui est docteur en
civilisation du monde anglophone c'est
l'auteur de du livre le triangle l
hexagone et norman à jarry et philosophe
il est l'auteur lui de la dignité ou la
mort éthique et politique de la race aux
éditions de la découverte
le fait que ce soit et georges tron le
fait que ce soit donald trump
aujourd'hui qui soit président des états
unis
est-ce que ça n'a pas joué aussi dans
dans la digne à sion qui a soulevé la
mort de georges floyd ne serait ce que
parce qu'elle n'avait pas l'air de la
digne et beaucoup lui qu'il avait l'air
davantage de s'indigner de l'indignation
qu'elle suscitait notamment des ddd
manifestations et on sait depuis que
lors de ces manifestations le président
des etats-unis a été obligé de se
réfugier dans l'abri antiatomique de la
maison blanche qui est pour le moins
humiliant alors norman el jarih vous
vous vivez aux états unis le fait que ce
soit george e donald trump c'est à dire
quand même un départ des présidents
américains qu'on soupçonne le plus de
racisme
ni nixon ni reggane ni même george bush
90 été soupçonné à ce point george bush
qui d'ailleurs vient de dire qu'ils ne
soutiendraient pas la réaction
la réélection de donald trump et là
encore c'est lié à la mort de georges
floyd we non c'est ce que vous disent
que vous dites est vrai pour autant il
faut pas oublier que le mouvement black
light mathieu est apparue sous la
présidence d'obama
je pense que disons cette logique qui
est tout de même je crois assez
française bon ça existe également aux
états unis bien sûr mais cette logique
de l'antitrust n'est pas la logique à
partir de laquelle on peut comprendre
ces événements bien entendu bien entendu
pas une réaction qu'on connaît mais
c'est une réaction
c'est une réaction très américaine il
appelle à sa base il convoque des mythes
qui sont des mythes fondateurs des
etats-unis comme la re conquête
territoriale en appelant l'armée en
disant on va tirer sur tout le monde et
c'est ce sont des opérations politiques
qui ne sont pas étonnantes mais ce sont
essentiellement des mots et en ce qui
concerne les actes en ce qui concerne le
traitement de la question raciale en
général et la question noire en
particulier il ne faut pas croire que
obama aurait réagi d'une manière
beaucoup beaucoup plus comment dire
généreuse beaucoup plus intelligente
comme je les dis le mouvement black
light manager est né sous obama et séné
à faire du sol avec un maire noir avec
des procureurs noir avec des forces de
police noir et c'est la classe moyenne
noire aux etats-unis n'est pas
fondamentalement différente dans la
manière dont elle expérimente le monde
est dans la manière dont elle veut se
faire voir et percevoir par les élites
blanches de cette élite blanche
elle-même elle a envie de se distinguer
elle a envie de marquer sa différence
d'avec la population prolétaires noir et
pour ce faire elle utilise les mêmes
méthodes répressives
elle utilise le même management que le
parti démocrate qui dit même utilise les
mêmes méthodes que le parti républicain
je dérape
je ne mets pas tous absolument sur le
même plan mais en ce qui concerne la
gestion des populations noires et en ce
qui concerne la gestion des révoltes
populaires en général il ya une
constante qui me constante north bide il
ya qu'à entendre les déclarations
aujourd'hui du candidat démocrate pour
se rendre compte
contre lui et shon qu'il n'ya pas une
différence de nature mais simplement une
différents
2° on a deux personnes qui sont dans la
même logique dans la même histoire
étasunienne c'est une histoire du
suprématisme blanc et qui est une
histoire de la démolition et de la
destruction des mouvements sociaux
alors effectivement il ya une question
raciale aux états unis il y en a
toujours eu et il y en a bu il y en a
toujours autant depuis l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
je le répète la ségrégation ça a duré un
siècle encore après l'abolition de
l'esclavagé en dépit du fait que il y a
eu un président des états unis noir en
dépit du fait qu'il ya aujourd'hui des
stars de cinéma noir que les les
musiciens noirs vendre plus de disques
que les blancs ce qui a mis très très
longtemps à arriver le premier cité
michael jackson le fait que les sportifs
noirs après avoir été interdit de de
sport avec les blancs sont devenus les
stars d'à peu près tout le le pays y
compris des des blancs on dirait que ça
n'a rien changé il ya toujours cette
question raciale aux états unis alors
que nous en france on estime qu'il n'y a
pas de questions raciales il n'y en a
pas puisque les noirs ont toujours eu
les mêmes droits dans la métropole tout
du moins ont toujours eu les mêmes
droits que les blancs donc il peut pas y
avoir de questions raciales on a admis
qu'il y avait eu une question juive
parce qu'à un moment on leur a mis une
étoile jaune sur le sur leur carte
d'identité qu'ils ont pris des trains
qu'on les a déporté et que la police
française n'était pas totalement
étrangère et là on a bien voulu admettre
qu'il y avait eu un problème racial mais
pas pour les noir et noir non il n'y a
pas de problème racial et on cite à vau
l'eau
le fait que ben que chocolat le célèbre
clown était une star énorme et qu'il
avait des femmes blanches en 1900 et que
les et que joséphine baker est arrivé
ici a voulu rester et que miles davis
c'est arrivé en france et s'est dit pour
la première fois on me traite comme un
être humain et on est très fier de ça on
se dit peut pas y avoir de problème
noire en france puisqu'ils ont les mêmes
droits que les autres naboulet soumahoro
alors je pense que dans les exemples que
vous venez de mentionner la
on va dire l'acceptation de pouvoir
envisager une communauté juive notamment
dans le contexte de la deuxième guerre
mondiale et dans ce contexte de
discrimination et de génocide
extrême est un exemple très parlant
puisque il a fallu il a fallu gérer la
population juive il a fallu qu'elle se
déclare aux préfectures il a fallu la
catégoriser la comté pour pouvoir la
livrer aux autorités allemandes de
manière à pouvoir l'exterminer je pense
que c'est un exemple parlant puisque si
on regarde l'histoire coloniale de la
france
il y a eu exactement le même genre de
pratique c'est à dire le comptage et
cette catégorisation qui ont toutes mené
enfin qui a mené à une des formes
extrêmes de coercition et la plus grande
étant l'existence même de l'existant en
fin de l'existence même de l'institution
de l'esclavagé en 1777 puisque cet
esclavage se déployer exclusivement dans
les territoires qu'on appelle les
territoires d'outre-mer c'est-à-dire
dans l' empire colonial français en
dehors de l'hexagone
quand vous êtes dans l'hexagone français
vous avez la création de la police des
noirs ça c'est 1777 est un acte
institutionnel c'est un acte
administratif
il y a des moyens qui sont octroyés par
l'état pour gérer cette population noire
desquels se trouvent sur le territoire
donc je pense que selon l'amnésie enfin
est ce ce recours à l'amnésie organisé
on va pouvoir s'arranger un peu avec la
réalité historique et même la réalité du
présent en france en dix ans les noirs
on les voit les noirs on les voit pas et
là vraiment on est dans ce schéma très
très très très stricte noir et noir et
blanc mais on pourrait parler d'autres
communautés on a parlé des juifs on
aurait pu parler des roms
on pourrait parler des communautés
asiatiques des communautés d'afrique du
nord en tout cas tout ce qu'on appelle
les non blancs
en france on a su les voir ce dont ont
bénéficié les africains américains
lorsqu'ils sont venus en france
hexagonale
c'est de la puissance des états unis ça
c'est un paradoxe
ils ont pu bénéficier de la nationalité
américaine et en cela ils étaient perçus
comme des êtres civilisés comme des
êtres
qui faisait partie de la patrie qui
avait aidé la france et l'europe et le
reste de l'europe notamment au cours des
deux guerres mondiales
c'est de ça dont ils ont bénéficié au
même moment dans l'hexagone il y à
d'autres populations noires qui ne sont
absolument pas traité de la même façon
et aujourd'hui encore on est prompt en
france en france hexagonale du moins à
citer donc les personnes que vous avez
mentionné que ce soit joséphine baker
que ce soit miles davis que ce soit
james baldwin qui est très très à la
mode actuellement richard wright on
pourrait citer des artistes des athlètes
des militaires enfin des étudiants il ya
plein de gens il ya je ne sais pas moi
analgesia exemple qui a obtenu un
doctorat de la sorbonne qui a obtenu un
doctorat de la sorbonne au début du 20e
siècle oui elle existe mais quand on
parle de cooper on ne parle pas des
soeurs nardal par exemple qui était
également diplômée de la sorbonne et qui
venait de qui venait de la martinique
voilà donc on a je sais pas un
aveuglement auquel on s'accroche
un aveuglement qui sert une fonction à
mes yeux
et cet aveuglement il passe sous silence
toute une histoire nationale qu'on ne
veut pas regarder en face si on est prêt
à accepter l'existence structurelle du
racisme aux états unis on est d'emblée
dans la question de jeu c'est pas des
empires coloniaux des grandes
découvertes de l'institution de
l'esclavagé et toutes ces choses ont
également exister au sein de l'histoire
française
donc vraiment je trouve même cela
épuisant de devoir répéter ce genre de
platitudes en fait de platitudes en coin
la france se distinguerait des états
unis en termes d'histoire coloniale et
l'histoire esclavagiste
la seule différence entre les deux
nations c'est que là la population
servile aux états unis se trouvaient sur
place et présente depuis 1619 c'est à
dire avant même l'existence la création
de cette nation et d'état que sont
devenus les étals et les états unis mais
la colonisation des amériques l'arrêt
par la france ça commence dès le xviie
siècle la martinique la guadeloupe la
guyane on pourrait parler de la réunion
pourrait parler la polynésie française
enfin tout tout tout ces territoires
sauf que les la population servent ils
n'étaient pas en masse présente dans
l'hexagone et la doublure
non mananjary comment je voulais juste
rappeler la louisiane il rappeler que la
france est partie prenante de ce que
sont aujourd'hui les états unis c'est à
dire que la france et les colons
français etc sont aussi des architectes
de ces états unis à l'histoire de ces de
ces nations est intrinsèquement lié mais
on est d'accord et tout le monde
reconnaîtra que la france dès l'instant
où elle sort de l'hexagone se comportent
en puissance coloniale esclaves en en et
esclavagiste etc etc
personne ne discutera mais en revanche
sur le territoire national on aime à
penser que je rappelle qu'on a on a
aboli l esclavage en france sur le
territoire français au moyen-âge et que
à partir de ce moment-là tout homme tout
esclave qui posait le pied sur le sol
français et est immédiatement a franchi
on est très fiers de cette histoire là
comme je le disais on est très fiers
d'eux d'une histoire qu'il faisait que
au moment même où à new york un un noir
ne pouvait pas entrer dans dans les
restaurants ne vais pas entrer dans les
cafés ne pouvait pas entrer dans les
hôtels quand bien même il était une star
il jouait sur scène et ils étaient
acclamés
il ne pouvait pas s'asseoir dans la
salle et je parle de new york comme
j'aurais pu dire los angeles ça
n'existait pas en france et on est très
fier de ça et je parlais du clown
chocolat il épousait il était il était
avec des femmes blanches et ça ne crée
aucun scandale aux etats unis ils
auraient été lynchées voilà alors on
peut pas dire non plus que la france et
les etats unis c'est exactement la même
chose mais c'est ma base on ne voit pas
des choses qu'elles n'existent pas c'est
à dire que la douleur et je dis ce n'est
pas parce qu'on ne voit pas les choses
qu'elles n'existent pas dans la même
période que vous citez la france faisait
travailler les les indigènes des
colonies par la force et donc est ce qui
est raconté ce qui n'est pas encore qui
ce qui n'est pas assez a raconté encore
aujourd'hui c'était la violence du
système des travaux forcés dans les
colonies d'afrique subsaharienne
c'était ce sont les différences aussi de
traitement encore aujourd'hui
des français qui habitent dans
martinique en guadeloupe en guyane ya
des codes des différences des
différences ceux qui sont notables des
différends par six ans par exemple
n'importe quelle personne dit
métropolitaine qui va travailler dans
les enseignes dans l'est dans l'est
toujours colonie française va obtenir
une prime à une prime à la vie chère qui
n'est pas accordée aux personnes qui
travaillent qui vivent et qui travaille
localement maboul soumahoro oui je
voulais dire que cette question de la
comparaison n'empêche pas la demande
même l'exigence de complexité c'est pas
parce que on regarde les deux pays et
qu'on essaye de faire des parallèles
compte que la conclusion sera que ces
deux pays sont identiques ils n'ont pas
à être identique et n'ont aucune raison
de l'être c'est pas du tout ce qu'on a
ce qu'on dit la question du racisme est
une question qui est extrêmement
complexe et qui évidemment va se
déployer de manière différente sur le
territoire des etats-unis sur le
territoire de france et ça c'est lié aux
histoires spécifique des donations mais
en tout cas dans la va dire dans dans la
question générale qui est celle de la
gestion des populations qui ont été
construites comme autres et dans chaque
pays aura sa façon qui lui est propre
c'est tout ce qu'on dit le racisme ne se
déploie absolument pas de la même façon
en france et aux états unis mais en tout
cas lorsqu'on parle des violences
policières
voilà on sait qu aux etats unis ces
violences policières touche de manière
vraiment prépondérante la communauté
africaine américaine
en france on s'est même si on a du mal à
compter que au delà des populations
d'apparence noir les populations
d'apparence arabes sont également
touchés si ce n'est plus touchée ça
c'est une spécificité française par
exemple sait pas on va pas retrouver une
un ciblage particulier des populations
arabes ou issus du moyen-orient par la
police aux états unis on sait aussi que
ces populations du moyen-orient aux
états unis sont catégorisées de manière
ethnique comme blanche
vous voyez ce que je veux dire ça on le
sait donc quand on fait des comparaisons
c'est j'essaye ne veux pas perdre mon
micro excusez moi
quand on fait des comparaisons on essaie
juste de regarder la question globale du
racisme et de voir comment d'une
question globale on peut passer à au
déploiement local au déploiement
national de cette même question et donc
quand vous parlez des africains
américains
on est obligé de regarder bien sûr la
couleur de la peau mais cette couleur de
la peau elle est adossée à la question
de la nationalité des africains
américains sont mieux traités parce
qu'ils sont américains
voilà et quand on est noir à cette
époque en france hexagonale et donc on
est relié ou qu'on peut être relié à l'
empire colonial français on va on est
toujours noir mais on va être traité
d'une autre façon et qui va être moins
favorable que la façon dont sont traités
les africains-américains le racisme
n'est aucunement simple parfois je
m'étonne vraiment 2d des approches
simplistes que des débats en fait sur la
question du racisme en france ce n'est
pas une comparaison terme à terme avec
les états unis
c'est une sorte de danalyse ou deux
prises en cause en cause par dont deux
thématiques bien globale qui vont avoir
leur spécificité une fois que l'on se
trouve aux états unis où qu'on se trouve
au brésil qu'on se trouve en grande
bretagne qu'on se trouve en allemagne ça
ne sera pas la même chose ça ne sera pas
la même chose
là n'est pas grave mais c'est il ya il
n'y a aucun aucun pays qui est meilleur
que l'autre on n'est pas en train de
dire que les états unis sont mieux que
la france ou que la france est pire que
les états unis tout ce que l'on dit
c'est que les deux pays sont des pays de
tradition raciste et qui gère ce racisme
de la manière dont ils ont choisi de
gérer de gérer cette cette institution
et cette institution a produit a des
conséquences et à un héritage qui nous
qui nous qu'il n'a plus qui nous
kidnappe tous actuellement c'est tout
nous sommes tous héritiers de cette
histoire qu'est ce que ça veut dire
d'être blanc qu'est ce que ça veut dire
d'être noir qu'est ce que ça veut dire
d'être riches d'être pauvre qu'est ce
que ça veut dire d'être policier ou pas
policier cesser ces grandes questions
que qui nous concerne tous et même si la
france a comment dire préserver son
hexagone de cette institution
d'escapades je rappelle la
l'instauration de cette police des noirs
des 1777 donc
des arguments qui ne peuvent pas tenir
comment comment quelle signification
donnez-vous à acea ces gens qui
s'agenouille depuis la mort de georges
floyd voilà des images récurrentes qui
énerve beaucoup les racistes d'ailleurs
alors quelle signification voulu voulu
donner à cet âge genou iman dans
manajary je pense que c'est un geste
disons qui est propre propice à l'ère
des réseaux sociaux qui permet disons de
propager une espèce de signes de
ralliement une espèce de signes qui est
en réalité à différentes facettes
puisque d'une part c'est la répétition
du geste de calling cap'tronic qu'il
avait lancé qu'il était le footballeur
américain
le champion de football américain qui
l'avait lancé qui servait signifier qu'
il ne se lève pas pour l'hymne américain
il refusait de se lever pour un hymne
qui porte avec lui l'image d'un pays qui
a exterminé les amérindiens qui a réduit
en esclavage les noirs et qui a été
symbole de conquête et de violences
raciales
donc cette agenouillement là il a été
d'une certaine manière le premier a
signifié c'était pour lui une façon de
jurés ou de comment dire de faire
contraste avec le garde à vous imposer
par le moment où l'hymne ne retentit
dans le stade il y à cela et s'il a
ajouté cet autre signification qui est
assez différente qui est évidemment
l'assassinât par chauvine de john floyd
donc on a ces deux significations là
d'une part capranie qui en a fait un
symbole du black power d'une certaine
façon c'est un peu similaire à ce fameux
point levé je ne me lève pas pour
l'amérique et d'autres parce ce geste
d'assassinât et donc ça rend d'une
certaine façon le symbole c'était ce
sera un petit peu un symbole à à lire
par an par roland barthes une mythologie
contemporaine
c'est quelque chose d'un petit peu d'un
petit peu difficile à lire d'un petit
peu contre
c'était à lire et c'est pour ça que
c'est assez étrange quand on voit par
exemple des images de policiers
étasunien agenouillé qui soi-disant qui
sincèrement je n'en sais rien tente de
montrer lors comment dire solidarité
avec les manifestants ou leur
désolidarisation avec leurs collègues
qui en réalité le fonds en répétant le
geste qui était le geste assassin qui a
ôté la vie de joe hart lane donc d'une
certaine façon c'est un geste assez
compliqué assez compliqué à lire et qui
à différents niveaux différentes
significations superposés et qui fait
que en tout cas lorsqu'on voit des
policiers des policiers le pratiquer
personnellement ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui me met très à l'aise et en
tout cas je ne me félicite pas
particulièrement je pense qu'il n'ya pas
particulièrement de raisons je félicité
de la solidarité des flics dans cette
affaire je pense que en tout cas les
personnes que j'ai rencontrées dans les
manifestations non vulgaire
il faut dire que le ministre de
l'intérieur en france christophe
castaner a donc annoncé que désormais la
le l'étranglement la prise de la prise
par le cou ne serait plus enseignée dans
l'est dans les écoles de police
en france il a fallu là encore la mort
de georges floyd vous d'y ajouter
quelque chose mabhouh la subaru sur
l'agenouillement surnage nous ment
peut-être pour continuer ce que vient de
déclarer quand même dire normal
excusez moi je pense qu il ya aussi
l'aspect de communication il ya des
symboles des symboles forts tout comme
on se rappelle des poings levés des
athlètes africains américains en 1968 à
mexico ce sont des images qui hante
encore on va dire la psyché collective
internationale ça peut compter on peut
se rappeler du symbole de l'élection du
premier président africain américain
barack obama en 2008 aux états unis
c'est un simple c'est un symbole
également mais c'est au delà des
symboles ce qui compte c'est vraiment
l'âme les transformations structurelles
sinon des images on pourrait en trouver
plein et on pourra leur faire dire
beaucoup de choses c'est pas si vous
m'entendez oui on vous entendez mais
puisque vous parlez de transformation
structurelle il y en a quand même qui
sont considérables depuis un siècle
quand quand les quand l'afrique est
colonisée on va dire en 1900 il ya 100
millions d'habitants en afrique c'est
très peu une des raisons d'ailleurs
celle esclavage qui a décimé ce
continent je veux dire par là que
l'afrique et les gens sont très peu
nombreux au moment même les blancs sont
très nombreux à d'habitants de la
planète sur quatre dans les années 20 et
blanc aujourd'hui c'est plus du tout le
cas
deux habitants sur quatre de la planète
sont asiatiques bientôt le troisième
sera africain d'ici 2050 et les blancs
pèsent de moins en moins lourd
est ce qu'on ne voit pas aussi dans
l'indignation générale qui a causé la
mort de georges klein la fin de ce que
certains appellent le privilège blanc
c'est à dire tout à coup on pensait
qu'on était non seulement les plus forts
les plus riches les plus intelligents
mais aussi que la démocratie les droits
de l'homme s'étaient nous et
qu'aujourd'hui on nous dit que c'est
peut-être pas nous personne ne se dévoue
moi je pense qu'il ya deux choses dont
vous parlez si je puis me permettre
c'est ce serait cette espèce de fantasme
du grand remplacement
et puis le privilégiant et ce sont deux
choses différentes le privilège blanc ce
qu'on appelle le privilège blanc c'est
c'est tout un ensemble de tout un
ensemble de choses qui font que kiki
enfin tout un ensemble de privilège
qu'on associe à la personne blanche
moi je peux en parler peut-être bon
temps si on est 12 % de la population ça
va plus durer très longtemps
moi je crois que c'est important c'est
important de ne pas oublier aussi le
continent africain quand on parle de
racisme
si je repense scission si on repense à
ce qu'on a pu entendre pendant la crise
du col haut du corps aux navires de la
crise sanitaire que
dont on est en train de sortir j'espère
y avait tout un tas de fantasque qui ont
été associées au corps noir et au
continent africain
dans un premier temps on a entendu c'est
une maladie qui ne touche pas les noirs
on a vu que c'était une maladie qui
touchait essentiellement les personnes
les plus défavorisées économiquement et
donc dans certains espaces ce sont les
personnes noires
on a entendu attention vers une
catastrophe en afrique
ils vont pas pouvoir gérer ça ils vont
tous mourir et c est en fait ça c'était
extrêmement agaçant c'était moi ça m'a
mis sa mamie ça m'a mis en colère parce
que j'avais l'impression qu'il y avait
une espèce de volonté pas de volonté de
désir de désir de devoir la catastrophe
arrive et ailleurs et et je pense que si
j'en parle c'est parce que je crois que
je crois que d'une certaine manière et
je ne sais pas encore comment parce que
tout ça c'est trop frais que le
mouvement en fait politique que nous
vivons aujourd'hui avec les manifestions
les manifestations contre le racisme et
les violences policières et la crise
sanitaire sont donc ont quelque chose à
voir maintenant on est comme on est
encore dans l'oeil du cyclone je
pourrais pas dire comment en fait il ya
comment quel est le lien mais il me
semble qu'il ya un lien et et pour en
revenir à ce que vous êtes de ceux dont
on parlait tout à l'heure sur la
différence entre les états unis et la
france
je fais juste une parenthèse il me
semble très important pour étudier ce
qui se passe pour étudier ce qui se
passe en france et pour aller dans le
même sens que ma boule assouma ronan pas
de comparer mais de partir de l'histoire
de france
et n'oublions pas que l'amérique
l'amérique telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
et un résultat net et le résultat de la
colonisation des européens
donc il ya quand même des choses sont
extrêmement complexes et et je crois que
cette histoire
pour en revenir à la question donc dû du
privilège blanc sait qu'il ya une prix
de conscience effectivement par des
personnes blanches du fait qu' elles
peuvent avoir des attitudes on va dire
des attitudes de privilégiés peuvent
elles peuvent bénéficier de privilèges
et elle s'en rendre compte
et comme aujourd'hui effectivement la
majorité numéraire des êtres humains
n'est plus européenne occidentale et
blanche
on s'aperçoit que que ce que comment
dire que il est je vais je vais
reformuler excusez moi mais je crois
qu'il est très il est très douloureux et
très difficile de s'apercevoir de
prendre conscience qu'on fait partie du
problème qu'on fait partie du de la
minorité numéraire dominante et je crois
que c'est c'est insupportable de le
ressentir
et je crois que cette prise de
conscience fait que tout à toute cette
jeunesse refuse d'être un blanc qui
bénéficient des privilèges je sais pas
si je suis très clair vous l'avez été
vous l'avez été mais ce sera le dernier
mot d'ailleurs à moi tous très rapide de
maboule numéro un mot très rapide très
rapidement puisque on a quand même eu
ben oui comme on aime le temps de
réfléchir un peu c'est là qu'on va
découvrir avec les évolutions
démographiques on sait qu'aux états unis
dans 15 ans ou 20 ans maximum les
minorités seront devenus la majorité par
exemple mais c'est le mouvement de
global on va voir que structurellement
et c'est là que ça content de revenir
aux structures aux institutions qu'on
n'aura pas besoin d'avoir un corps blanc
pour agir comme un blanc c'est ça le
camp jeudi que le racisme est complexe
c'est que ça va au delà des corps il
fait partie de la construction de ces
catégories raciales mais les
fonctionnements dépasse les catégories
raciales c'est à dire que quand on a un
président aux états unis qu'il y est un
président africain américain
on sait que ce président en dépit de son
corps noir n'est pas là pour représenter
les intérêts des noirs c'est pas comme
ça que ça fonctionne c'est ça le
systémique le structurel
l'institutionnel d'oxydé blanc se
lamente en se disant que c'est le grand
remplacement vous inquiétez pas les
institutions sont telles qu'elles vont
elles vont vous survivrez que d'autres
personnes non blanches vont continuer à
faire le travail
il y aura moins de privilèges individuel
ça ce sera le dernier mot n'est déjà
drôlement dépassé que j'ai moi dans ma
nadjari
merci tous les trois d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m